hablemos un poco acerca de cómo trabajan
los márgenes cuando hablamos de
contratos de futuros
ahora bien veamos un poco los términos
de un contratista que negocia mil libras
de manzanas con una fecha de entrega
para el 15 de noviembre y asumiendo que
esta es una fecha futura digamos que en
estos momentos las manzanas tienen un
cierto precio pero para esa fecha y ese
entonces las manzanas tendrán un valor
de 200 dólares y estos 20 dólares que
estoy subrayando aquí serán lo que
especifica el contratista que se debe de
marcar como un margen inicial los 20
dólares de aquí y el margen inicial
aborda que es con lo que se debe de
iniciar este futuro y en algunas
ocasiones será especificado como un
monto de un dólar como lo hice en estos
momentos y algunas otras ocasiones puede
ser concertado como algún tipo de
porcentaje pero finalmente para el
precio que haya sobre la entrega así que
de ambas maneras se tiene que poner los
20 dólares
esta persona estará de acuerdo a hacerlo
por la cantidad de libras acordadas de
manzanas para la contraparte el día
el 15 de noviembre por 200 dólares o lo
que vendría siendo 20 centavos por libra
ahora digamos que este peso de 200
dólares fue arreglado en sus mentes pero
vamos a ver que al día siguiente el
mismo contrato está entre otras dos
partes y es negociado a un precio de
entrega de 190 dólares entonces
repentinamente esta parte de aquí el
comprador se siente tonto y se siente
así porque dice yo acordé comprar algo
por 200 dólares en el futuro y el otro
compañero de repente lo acuerdo a
comprar con alguien más en el mercado a
190 dólares entonces el que lo acordó a
los 190 fue demasiado inteligente
acordar un precio mayor de venta y ahora
en el mercado la gente lo comercializa
más barato así que esta especie de 10
pesos ahora eres para ganancias pero
para la gente es mejor comercializar lo
que entra en un contrato futuro entonces
voy a reajustar su contrato futuro con
un precio de fecha de entrega a 190
dólares pero para hacer las cosas justas
estos chicos tendrán 10 dólares en su
poder el estado obteniendo 10 dólares
pensando que está dando el precio hacia
entonces haciendo este ajuste como él
obtiene 10 dólares de ganancia por hacer
un mejor trato entonces para que esto
sea justo necesitaremos que el otro
chico también obtenga 10 dólares
entonces tachamos estos 20 dólares de
aquí y pondremos aquí 10 dólares y los
otros 10 dólares los pondremos en la
cuenta de margen de este otro chico
entonces lo que estamos diciendo es que
si él obtendrá 10 dólares menos por
tener como un mejor precio a la fecha de
la entrega entonces ahora mismo
pondremos estos 10 dólares a su cuenta
de margen y habrá acumulados los 30
dólares y si este precio siguiera
haciendo 17 16 hasta 15 dólares este
chico no tendrá que poner nada pues
exactamente aquí se activa su margen de
mantenimiento que actualmente tiene lo
exacto para que no tenga que invertir
nada y bien si haber presión fuera de
estos 185 dólares tendríamos que repetir
el procedimiento como de repartición a
las cuentas de margen por un lado del
pie de cinco dólares el comprador y por
otro lado al vendedor si lo acumulan 35
dólares en su cuenta y ahora este chico
solo tiene 5 dólares en su cuenta y como
el mínimo del margen de mantenimiento
son estos 10
es se activaría una llamada al margen
entonces acudir a algún lugar para
lograr obtener los 15 dólares y llegar a
alcanzar el margen inicial una vez más
pues cada vez que bajamos del margen de
mantenimiento que eran los 10 dólares se
activa nuestra llamada al margen y
tenemos que llegar al margen inicial una
vez más que eran los 20 dólares
iniciales